these giants they're 22 and 16 on the
road that's some of the best with regard
to wins and losses paced by andrew haney
now haney last four starts that's just
kind of good but very good
hold the string a couple of fastballs
then a couple of changeups that
strikeout won this great arm action
mandarine went right back to it
back-to-back change-ups the one out for
mike yastremski
punches one
to shallow left field this time
for a base hit first hit of the game
it's got a high three-quarter release
that's perfect hitting two runners in
scoring position for one of the most
dangerous hitters buster posey pitch
count your favor
and that's going to get the first run
home
as iglesias throws out buster posey but
it's one to nothing giants rough over to
third
[Applause]
there's a bunt by belt
rolling rolling it hits the bag and that
gets another run home
but they were giving him the bunt
and belt said hey
if i beat this out that's a run it's
kind of risky but it worked
hey that's a line drive
in the scorebook with an rbi
so now here is the red hot flores and
that's a high drive deep left center
field way back there
[Applause]
the right-handed hitter is on fire
two homers yesterday in a four hit game
and the first pitch tonight
he launches one again
four-nothing giants here's anthony
diesclafani with justin upton to lead
off against him field here's a called
strike three on the outside corner
diesel funny throws a slider
oh one pitch walsh swings and hits a
little squib shot it's gonna land
fair in shallow left field
walsh wasn't even running ohtani to
third and he'll stop there as crawford
comes up with a ball the giants had the
big overshift on so there was nobody
anywhere in the neighborhood crawford
had to sprint a long way to get that
ball and
walsh even though he wasn't running
makes it into second
so now anthony rendon pitches and rendon
hits a high fly ball right field
yostremski's there underneath it
and he makes the catch for out number
three
the little bloop double does not cost
the giants to go to the second inning
mauricio dubois leads off first ball
swinging
deep center
still going still going and off the wall
and that would hit above the yellow line
so it is a home run
for mauricio duvonne first ball swinging
look at that ball out on the outer third
back spins it carries and the giants
have a five-nothing lead second and
third nobody out the giants with a
five-nothing lead
hung that slider racing in and getting
there dubon
tagging and bluffing the stassi the
throw cut off by brandon bell look at
the infield back hits the ball in the
air gets jammed doesn't hit it far
enough and that's a free out that's a
good job by diesel fauna of getting that
out so now here is david fletcher ball
player
it's a good pitch up there in the zone
shallow right is stremski
stassi goes back to tag but he's not
going anywhere
again a very shallow fly ball two down
so not justin upton let's watch where
buster sets up
struck him out
with that cutter or slider and the
inning is over
ohtani to lead off for the angels here
in the last of the third two and two
he struck him out and he got him to go
after one that was up in his eyes that
time
well if you pay attention to that at bat
you can see diesel funny and buster
trying to pitch ohtani up in the zone
he's a low ball hitter
and they want to show them the pitch up
at the letters and the eyes and they get
a swing it's three and two to walsh
he struck him out so he goes up in the
zone at 95 for a couple pitches and
walsh is late and then what does he do
takes about four mile miles an hour off
and goes right down the middle now we
move to the last half of the fourth
inning five to nothing giants here's max
stassie to lead off now a fastball on
the outside corner strike three call
renifo now
here's a big hopper to beld who's going
to feed diesel funny and he doesn't get
there in time
i don't know what happened there he got
a little tied up approaching the bag
and rendezfo managed to beat it out yeah
as a high chopper belt had to wait can't
really charge that ball
i think the giants are asking them to
look at this one yep this call is going
to go and it does go in their favor as
mike kastromski
good fastball genie over the outside
corner that ball's right there max
stassi didn't even move his club and
there's a swing and a miss at a
curveball and boy ruff was really fooled
on that one struck him out here is
donovan solano
instead he gets a chase a change up away
that's three swinging strikeouts for
solano
we'll chop her up
and it takes a weird hop right over top
fletcher
like a top spin bouncer andrew haney
goes down
that's a great job of base running by
brandon crawford too never
taking anything for granted
watch how hard cro how hard crawford's
running right here after the ball gets
right on the edge of that grass right
here he knows i can get to third here is
slater at the plate
that's strike three outside corner the
founder taylor ward right at her against
right-handed six strikeouts in the game
for d stefani and now the o2 pitch
swinging to miss he struck him out with
a high fastball
wow he made short work of ward why not
jared walsh now to do walsh who's having
such a good year but tonight he has
struck out twice against dee slavani and
anthony rendon will come up
there's a fastball on the outside corner
strike three call he strikes out the
side jose quintana takes the baseball
out of the bullpen is buster posey
here's the next pitch on posey and that
one a up fools him
92 93 94 curveballs at upper 70s and
change up here at 88. here's brandon
belt full count here on belt
and here's the pitch and he takes a cold
third strike on the outside corner got
him looking and quintana strikes out the
side
one more chance for the halo there's
jimmy shurfy university of oregon he's a
duck on for the sixth time this year
just caught surefy against the slugger
jared walsh one-two pitch
is popped up fastball way in and walsh
swung at it anyway
behind second solano is there to make
the catch for out number one gets max
stassi to the plate here's the pitch
from sherpy
called strike three the slider he takes
advantage of the huge strike zone that
is out number two runners at first and
second two down the 3-2 is swung on and
foul tip this one right into the mid of
posey strike three
and the game is over
the giants pitch a shutout in anaheim